Jackson on Kuzma Oh garbage on Ingram
Guzman's having a good first half plays
he could and I said that earlier but I
mean he just is he's so talented he
cures me
offensively as LeBron James
you make a kick point as you see Koosman
out with 25 points in with an angle 3 no
good
Oh Callisto gets in here that just can't
happen Stephenson fouled give Electra's
credit they got the rebound
they got it there and the Kings blogger
Dan opportunity to get the rebound
[Applause]
just dishes of ground just dishes the
ball inside
[Applause]
he's underneath he puts it up on her
[Applause]
[Music]
just a Jackson actually it's the penalty
situation the announcement they're the
only team of the league with two players
off the bench averaging at least fifteen
spot he scores with a little runner are
a much better shooter from that position
as we get another look at KU shooting
his runner develops foot ten Lonzo visas
for child whose money spends beautiful
school
boom sketching it and then finishing
another look at that spin by cooze as he
gets into the painting the West they
killed this Alexander founded long-range
jump shots to his mother he's going
downhill he's going all the way he's
storing her now he's core down at this
score 628 to go in the half is goose
lays it up lays it in the Lakers trail
by six averages nearly 20 points the
animals sit wallpaper cheese box and a
better mr. Tambor that's what I'm
talking about we're cruises game is
really elevate gobbled up tonight that's
for sure
leave the Lakers and boards Zoe's going
to try a three launches and scores it
couple acres a little bit it's only down
to 10:31 Ingram long distance can't dial
it up tapped all the way out by Chandler
a fresh 41 - guru story
floater that he's pretty much shut down
pack it was on the attack
Oh Chandler was there good defense so
would so uh pad for clues ha somehow he
controls it in stores four and a half to
play
Kuzma default a gallon are had been
thrown smells it down well because her
job cause crews are such a threat at a
chance at a three-point another look at
coos setting up who Liam's for that um
well she goes right past got an RIT bit
on the 3.05 for the Lakers pick it out
to treatment he's gonna go baseline good
traffic fines Lonzo Wow in traffic lungs
will not only catches it but finishes
Josh hard what a half for Josh 17 points
on a 6 for 9 even
whose butt kisses it off the glass for
deuce we have the exact Syria vertically
hold on Lake this Carter Boyd the
three-game slide and it is
caldwell-pope with the aunt waad coos
with the assist three-point opportunity
coming to kCPT these reads those
situations perfectly Beasley is waiting
to come in for the Lakers Kentavious
caldwell-pope pizza the direction of
Alonso fall with a little sick sack
dried to the bestop he's struggling from
the perimeter so that's a good drive by
him sounds well and is it excused but
the bottom line is compete to defend be
aggressive and be the same plan when the
front is a bonus to have LeBron James
chasing a reset with a shot clock at 10
Griffin just again shoot it again if
they're gonna give dare you to make that
shot
you're a pro look at choice by putting
on the Jets at the last second when they
say well what's the difference between
Lonzo ball and Andre Drummond well one
guy has to shoot it to make us cool
absolutely Kuzma beautiful fake got
Griffin on his feet big block on Reggie
Miller my friend
Blake Griffin doing a very good job
reading double-teams and making plays
nice play by him a key that time and
then Kyle Guzman with a smart play
cutting to the rim good job pushing the
basketball Magee realizing he's running
full steam ahead patiently waits for
Kuzma good team
let's go and challenge Dwane Casey's
former team the Toronto Raptors the best
record in a lake Kuzma down cart gets
the easy two as the Pistons then get
back if you don't get back in transition
this is lackadaisical for the Pistons
getting back and a Lakers good job
running a caldwell-pope couple of
possessions ago here's Kuzma from the
corner that's good back-to-back threes
for the Lakers without him Javad
averages seven assists per game and
James
offensive rebound Drummond there's Magee
with a SWAT Drummond's got eight
offensive rebounds already in the game
they're gonna get a blocking call here
on Reggie Jackson and Sunday home
against Cleveland for Claude the three
with two ku says I will take it and make
it yes it's his night ladies and
gentlemen
32 already that can really heat up and
knock down shots so get shooters on the
floor and call the roll Galloway
[Applause]
boy chance
a new career-high 41 and he's going for
42 but clinic and the fans raining down
coos from the stands here at Staples Wow
chilly around 17 this year some of that
is the schedule they played the toughest
schedule in the league how about that
pass and the three by caldwell-pope from
the corner terrific
anchored all by Gobert nice play by Hart
there to strip Mitchell kuzmic throws it
down by Mitchell off the foot of heart
leads to a easy transition opportunity
there night in the lost of Houston
blowout by the Rockets ventures into the
lane and scores he's got all the shots
for 420 in the game a couple of nights
ago he put up 500 shots in his game out
there whose look nobody talking or at
least not talking at the right time and
they opened the gate and coos right down
the gut for the flush he's got eight the
game so that's his second board tonight
for 611 points that's his line here
the first half
[Applause]
good screen the better screen you said
the more chance you get the shot
try the dog the charge got knocked down
but got up quick enough to get the
rebound who's not with 11.7 goes all the
way for the flush look out throw it down
up gift three gets the rebound and then
pushes it all the way up the floor
nobody really stops the ball so he gets
an easy play who's one with 12 to shoot
boys Tristan Thompson held its ground so
little step back the twos not an easy
shot mate by kuzu there went right
around Katie Peas Kuzma launches who's
back he's got it one quickly
kcp on its way back there tapped out
Lonzo will corral it to 24 seconds left
Cruz but God
[Applause]
three-point game gate this game is kcp
missed his tapped out and cut a a
Koosman man in his face
shoots it scores it makes it a
three-point game all the Cavs need
though is a free throw
well two threes here late actually it's
gonna come this way and there is kcp
straightaway Gibson comes out guzmán
scores 10 seconds left with a sense of
urgency it doesn't matter who you're
playing you can't look at this standings
though this team's lost 12 in a row
we're good Lonzo and just get a drive
kick kcp on its way not close but Lonzo
collects it that's the way to start just
no moving another look at that shot by
coos the running hook shot just couldn't
get a good shot away I think that last
offensive foul on crews kind of changed
his mind on the shot Chandler's
underneath on the tight quarter past
from Kuzma timeout Chicago to this pass
by kuzmic to Tyson to put the Lakers up
by two
[Music]
starters back on the floor five on the
shot clock
there that's a really good call now
you've gotten the lead back or you got
in the game
[Applause]
Lakers were down by 20 of 17 his people
red and Skaar slick ha he moved his body
out of the way because that was going to
be a charge on Schroeder right there I'm
due a later on the drive and draws the
foul
who Westbrook 5 to 10 from three-point
land but just to 15 shooting two scoops
bow tie up loose bunker 33% see the
Lakers have a little bit of a bender
Pamela's 40 points in the paint a total
stroke he's getting up
[Music]
[Applause]
and for foul getting it off of the
imbalance playing right here okay go up
and make a poster on somebody big fella
kazoo box it is a season-high hard
played by Ferguson gets it inside
[Applause]